hello this is Matthew with simply learn
and today we can go through our second
round of interview questions following
on from the previous video that we did
last week so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna go through and cover the
following areas
so we've already covered some areas but
as a reminder what DevOps really allows
us to cover our number of areas for
interview questions so there's going to
be a general interview questions source
code management questions continues
integration and testing questions and
then configuration management
containerization and continuous
monitoring we've already covered part
one in the video and there should be a
link at the top of the screen they'll
take you to part one what we're going to
do in this video is go through part two
where we get deep dive on configuration
management containerization and
continuous monitoring specifically
focusing on tools such as chef puppet
and sport dhaka and negros so let's just
get into their first section which is
configuration management so one of the
questions that you'll get asked right
away is why do you have SSL certificates
used for chef really fundamentally your
immediate answer should be security SSL
provides for a very high level of
private security and private and public
key pairing this really is essential to
ensure that you have a secure
environment throughout your entire
network the second part should be that
if you're using SSL and you're using the
private public key model within this
cell you're able to guarantee the
systems on your network that the chef
that you'll be able to validate that the
nodes within your network that chef is
validating against actually are the real
nodes themselves not imposters so you
will also be asked some questions and
such as the following which is the
following commands would you use to stop
or disable the HTTP service when the
system boots and you'll typically get
four responses and there'll be hash tag
systemctl disable httpd service or is
its system disabled HTTP service system
disabled HTTP D or the final option
which is systemctl disabled httpd
service your answer should be the first
one which is hash tag
CTL disable HTTP service so chef comes
with a series of tools that allow it to
function effectively and one of the
tours that you're gonna be asked about
is what is Test Kitchen and Test Kitchen
is essentially a command-line tool that
allows you to be able to test out your
cookbook before you actually deploy to a
real note so some of the commands that
you would use are for instance if you
want to create an instance of Test
Kitchen you would do kitchen create if
you want to destroy an instance after
you created it you do kitchen destroy
and if you want to be able to combine
multiple instances you would do kitchen
converge so a question you'll get is
around chef is how does chef apply
differ from chef client as we're
fundamentally the difference between
them is that chef applied will validate
the recipe that you're working on
whereas chef client looks to apply
invalidate the entire cookbook that's
run in your server environment so one is
focused on the recipe and the other is
focused on the entire cookbook so there
are some differences when you're working
with different command lines so for
instance I'm when you're working with
puppets and you're working with one
version of puppets and you want to do
what is the command to sign a requested
certificate the top example here is for
puppet version 2.7 whereas the lower
option here is for puppet version 3 and
I something to bear in mind when you're
going through your interview process is
that the tools that are used within a
continuous integration continuous
delivery DevOps model do vary and so you
want to be able to talk knowledgeably
about the different versions of the
tools so that when you're talking to
your interviewer you're able to show you
the deep knowledge that you have which
open-source or community tools do you
use to make puppet more powerful and
essentially this question is going to be
asking you to look beyond the core
foundation of puppet itself and so the
three options you have is are being able
to track configurations with JIRA which
you should be doing anyway but it's a
great way to be able to clearly
communicate the work that's been done
with puppet a version control can be
extended
get and then the changes should be
passed through Jenkins so the three
tools you ought to be looking at
integration with JIRA git and Jenkins so
what are the resources in puppet well
fundamentally there are four the
resources are basic unit of any
configuration management tool they are
the features of the nodes they are the
written catalog and the execution of the
catalog on a node so as we dig deeper
into puppet one of the things that you
are likely to be asked for regarding
puppet is what is a class in puppet and
so a class and puppet is really the name
blocks in your manifest that contain the
various configurations but listen can
include services files and packages and
we have on the screen here an example of
what a class would look like when you
write it out and you may want to
memorize just one class don't memorize
just a whole set of classes just
memorize one the person that's
intervening you is just really looking
for someone who has a working knowledge
they're not looking for you to have
memorized complete massive classes but
having one small class to be able to
illustrate the experience you have is
extremely valuable to the interviewer
particularly if it's a technical
interview so as we move into ansible one
of the things that you're going to be
asked around as well is what is ansible
role so a role is it an independent
block of tasks and variable files and
templates embedded with inside of the
playbook so example we have here on the
screen actually shows you one role
within a playbook and in this role it is
to install Tomcat on a node again as
with previous question within puppets of
a class it's probably good to have
memorized just one or two roles so you
can talk knowledgeably about ants both
when you're having your interview so
when you're working with ansible when
should you be using the curly brackets
and so just as a frame of reference
there's often two different ways that
these kind of brackets are referred to
they're either referred to as French
brackets or curly brackets either way
and what you'll be wanting to ask is
when would you use these specific types
of brackets within and
sport and really the answer comes down
into two things one is that it makes it
easier to distinguish strings and
undefined variables and the second is
for putting together conditional
statements when you are actually using
variables in the example we have here is
this prints the value of and we have
food and we have to then put in the
variable conditional statement of foo is
defined as something so what is the best
way to make content reusable and
redistributable with ansible and there's
really essentially three the first is to
include sub module or another file in
your playbook the second is to import an
improvement of an include which ensures
that a final it's added only once and
then the third is roles to manage the
tasks within the playbook so a question
you will be asked is provide a
differences between ansible and puppets
so if we look at as well it's a very
easy agentless installation it's based
on Python you can configure it with
llamó and there are no support for
windows in contrast puppet is an
agent-based installation it's written in
Ruby the configuration files are written
in DSL and it has support on all popular
operating systems so we dig deeper into
the actual architecture and so it has a
much more simple architecture and it's
definitely a push only architecture in
contrast to puppet it's a more
complicated but more sophisticated
architecture where you're able to have a
complete environment managed by the
puppet architecture so let's get on to
our next section which is
containerization so let's go through and
you're gonna be asked to explain what
the architecture of docker is and docker
really is the most popular
containerization environment so doctor
uses a client-server architecture and
the docker client is a service which
runs in a command-line and and then the
docker daemon which is run as a REST API
drill in the command line will accept
the requests and interacts with the
operating system in order to build the
docket images and run the docker
containers and then the docker image is
a template of instructions which is used
to create containers the docker
container is
an executable package of applications
and its dependencies together and then
finally the docker registry is a service
to host and distribute document other
users so you'll also be asked to provide
and what are the advantages of docker
over virtual machine and and this is
something that comes up very
consistently in fact and you may want to
even extend it as having what are the
differences between having a dedicated
machine a virtual machine and a docker
or doctor like environment and really
the arguments for docker are just
absolutely fantastic you know first of
all docker does contain and occupy
docker containers occupy significantly
less space than a virtual machine or a
dedicated machine the boot up time on
docker is significantly faster than a vm
containers have a much better
performance as they are hosted in a
single docker image docker is highly
efficient and very easy to scale
particularly when you start working with
kubernetes easily portable across
multiple platforms and then finally for
space allocation docker
date volumes can be shared and reused
among multiple containers the argument
against virtual machines is significant
and particularly if you're going into an
older environment where a company is
still using actual dedicated hardware
and haven't moved to a cloud or
cloud-like environment your arguments
for docker I can be very very persuasive
be very clear on what the advantages are
for docker over a virtual machine
because you want to be able to
succinctly share them with your team and
this is something that's important when
you're going through the interview
process but also equally important
particularly you're working with a
company that's transitioning or going
through a digital transformation where
they aren't used to working with tools
like danke you need to be able to
effectively share with that team what
the benefits are so how do we share
docker containers with different nodes
and in this instance what you want to be
able to do is leverage the power of
docker swarm so doctor swarm is a tool
which allows the IT administrators and
developers to create and manage clusters
of
swarm nodes within the darker platform
and there are two elements to the node
there's the manager node and then
there's the the worker node the manager
node as you'd assume Maja's the entire
infrastructure and the worker node is
actually the wall
of the agent as it gets executed so what
are the commands to create a docker swan
and so here we have an example of what a
manager node would look like and what
you created a swarm on your Maginot you
can now add worker nodes to that swarm
and again when you're stepping through
this process be very precise in the
execution part that needs to be taken to
be able to effectively create a swarm so
start with manager node and then you
create a worker node and then finally
when a note is initializes imagine node
it can immediately create a token and
that token is used for the worker notes
and associating the IP address with the
worker nodes question 17 how to run
multiple containers using a single
service it is possible to run multiple
containers a single service by using
docker compose and docker compose will
actually run each of the services in
isolation so that they can interact with
each other the language used to write
out the compose files that allow you to
run the service is called llamo and
llamo stands for yet another markup
language so what is the use of a docker
file so docker file actually is used for
creating docker images using the build
command so let's go through and show on
the screen what that would look like and
this would be an opportunity where if
you're actually in a technical interview
you could potentially even ask hey can I
draw on a whiteboard and show you what
the architecture for using the build
command would look like and what the
process would look like again
when you're going through an interview
process as someone who interviews a lot
of people one of the things I really
like is when an interview candidate does
something that's slightly different and
in this instance this is a great example
of where you can stand up to the
whiteboard and actually show what can
actually be done through actually
creating images on the whiteboard very
quickly little square boxes where you
can actually show the flow for creating
a build environment as an architect this
should be something that you're
comfortable doing and by doing it in the
interview and suddenly you want to ask
permission before you actually do it but
doing this in the interview really helps
demonstrate your comfortable feelings of
working with these kind of architecture
so back to the question of creating a
docker file so we go through and we have
a docker file that achievement goes head
and creates the docker image which then
in turns creates the docker container
and then we are able to push that out up
to a docker hub and then share that
docker hub with everybody else as part
of that docker registry with the whole
network so what are the differences
between docker image and docker
containers so let's go through the
docker image so the docker images are
templates of a docker container an image
is built using a docker file it Nate
stores that docker file in a docker
repository or a docker up and you can
use docker hub as an example and the
image layer is a read-only file system
the docker container is a collection of
the runtime instances of a docker image
and the containers are created using
docker images and they are stored in the
docker daemon and every container is a
layer is a read/write filesystem so you
can't replace the information you can
only append to it so well you can
actually use Yammer or writing your so a
question you can be asked is instead of
yema what can be an alternate file to
build docker compose so yeah mel is the
one that is the default but you can also
use JSON so if you are comfortable
working with Jason and my there is
something that should be a get
comfortable with is you want to be able
to use that to name your files and it's
a frame reference adjacent is a logical
way of being able to do value pair
matching using a driver script like
syntax so you're gonna be asked to how
to create a docker container so let's go
through what that would look and we'll
break it down task by task so the task
is going to be create a my sequel docker
container so to do that you want to be
able to build a docker image or pool
from an existing docket image from a
docker repository or hub and then you
want be able to then use docker to
create a new container which has my
sequel from the existing docker image
simultaneously the layer of readwrite
filesystem is also created on top of
that image and below that at the bottom
the screen we have what the command
lines look for that so what is the
difference between a registry and a
repository so let's go through
that so for the docker registry and
repository for the registry we have dr.
Rush Rhees an open-source server-side
service used for hosting and
distributing docker images whereas in
contrast for repositories a collection
or multiple versions of a docker image
in a registry a user can distinguish
between docker images with their tag
names and then finally on the registry
docker also has its own default retreat
called docker hub for the repository it
is a cutting of multiple versions of
docker images it is stored in a docker
registry and it has two types of public
and private registry so you can actually
create your own Enterprise registry so
you're gonna be asked you know what are
the cloud platforms that support and
docker really you know list them all and
we have listed here Amazon Web Services
Microsoft Azure Google cloud Rackspace
but you could add in there IBM bluemix
could put in red hats really any of the
cloud service providers out there today
do support docker it's just become an
industry standard so what is the purpose
of expose and publish commands in Dhaka
so if we go through expose is an
instruction using docker file where as
publish is used in docker run command
for expose it is used to expose ports
within a docker network or as with
polishes can be used outside of a docker
environment for exposing is a
documenting instruction used at the time
of building an image and running a
container where as we publish these
users to map a host port to a running
container port for expose is the command
used in Dhaka whereas for published we
use the command dash p4 when we're doing
our command line used in Dhaka and
examples of these are exposed 8080 or
with docker we would put in or for
publish we'd do the example docker run -
d/p and then 0 0 0 88 colon 80 as our
command line so this look at continuous
monitoring so with continuous monitoring
how does naggers help in continuous
monitoring of systems applications and
service and so this is really just a
high-level question of using now years
with
your environment and you should be able
to just come back very quickly and say
Negus allows you to help manage the
servers and check if they've been
sufficiently utilized and if there are
any tasks failures that need to be
addressed and so there are three areas
of utilization and risk that you want to
be able to manage this is being able to
verify the status and services of the
entire network the health of your
infrastructure as a whole and in
applications are working properly
together with an web services and api's
that are reachable so the second
question you'll be asked is how does
Negus help in continuous monitoring of
systems applications and services so
it's able to do this by having the
initial Nagast process and scheduler and
the additional plugins that you would
use for your network connect with the
remote resources and the negative web
interface to be able to run status
checks on a predefined schedule so what
do you mean by nagira moat plugging
executor or the mpre of nag years so
mpre allows you to execute plugins on
lengths UNIX machines that allow you to
do additional monitoring and machine
metrics such as disk usage CPU load etc
what are the ports used by Nagios for
monitoring purposes in this example
there are three and they're easy to
remember so I would memorize these three
but they're essentially ports five six
six six five six six seven and five six
six eight so there are two types of
checks within a year so you will be
asked for what is an active and passive
check in nine years so an active check
and is initiated by the Nagios process
and is run on a regular schedule
a passive check is initiated in formed
by an external application or process so
this may be where a system is failing
and checks our results are submitted in
our years for processing and to continue
with this for what is an active and
passive check active checks are
initiated by the check logic within the
nanos daemon now yes will execute a
plug-in and pass information about what
needs to be checked plugin will then
check the operational state of the
host:oh service and then will process
the results of the host
service check and send out notifications
in contrast with the passive check it is
an external application that initiates
the check it writes the results of the
check to an external command line file
Negus reads the external command file
and places a results of all passive
checks in a queue for later processing
so you can go back and revalidate and
then- may send out notifications log
alerts etc depending on the results that
they get from checking the information
so you're gonna be asked to explain the
main configuration file and its location
in a year so the main configuration file
consists of a number of directives that
affect how neno's operates so consider
this as the configuration file that's
read by both now years processor and the
CGI's so this will allow you to be able
to manage the main configuration file
that is placed into your settings
directory so what is the negative
network analyzer and again hold out your
forefingers because there are four
options here so the Nagios network
analyzer r1 provides an in-depth look at
all your network traffic source and
security threats to allows system admins
together high-level information on the
health of your network 3 provides a
central view of your network traffic and
bandwidth data and then 4 allows you to
proactive in resolving outages abnormal
behavior and threats before they affect
critical business processes so what are
the benefits of HTTP and SSL certificate
monitoring's with Nagios so with HTTP
certificate monitoring it allows you to
have increased server and services and
application availability obviously very
important fast detection of network
outages and protocol failures and allows
web transaction and web service
performance monitoring the SSL
certificate monitoring allows you for
increased website availability frequent
application availability and provides
increased security so explained
virtualization with Nagios so in
responses the first thing you should be
able to talk about is how Negus itself
can run on many different virtualization
platforms including Microsoft Visual PC
VMware Zen Amazon ec2 etc etc
so just make sure you get that right off
the bat now you see it was able to
provide capabilities tomorrow and so
much of metrics on different platforms
it allows for ensure for quick detection
of service and application failures and
has the ability to be able to monitor
against many metrics including CPU usage
memory networking and VM status so name
the three variables that affect
recursion inheritance in Nagios and it
is named use and register so name is a
template name that can be referenced in
other object definitions use specifies
the name of the template object that you
want to inherit its properties of
variables from and register indicates
whether or not the object definition
should be registered to dahlias and on
the right-hand side of the screen we
have an example of what that script
would look like again you may want to be
able to memorize this as it's something
that you can achieve write down and show
someone if you're going through a
technical interview so why is now yo
said to be object-oriented and
fundamentally comes down to the object
configuration format you can use in your
object definitions it allows you to
inherit properties from other object
definitions and this is typical
object-oriented development and is now
applied for the Nagios environment so
some of the objects that you can inherit
our services host commands and time
periods so finally explain what is state
talking in now years and so there are
really four options here when you're
talking about States talking so States
talking is used for logging purposes in
Nagios it allows you to enable for a
particular host or service that
negatives will watch over very carefully
and it will log any changes it sees in
the output of the check results and then
finally helps the analysis of log files
so hopefully you learned something from
our second interview DevOps question
video if there were questions that
you've been asked in DevOps interviews
that we didn't cover here please put
them in the comments below we're always
looking for great feedback that we can
use to be able to improve the services
that we have here today
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here